Dalila I want to ask you many questions
about your documentary can you dig this
in terms of the filmmaking aspect but
for one quick moment I just want to go
to something you said on another show
and I think you mentioned that halfway
through making the film you weren't sure
that you could continue I'm sure it was
a emotional thing for you anybody who
sees the film will definitely see how
that would be possible but did you
change your mind in terms of wanting to
make another film after can you date
this was in the can and definitely I've
gotten over that that hurdle it is true
that I I'm probably more reticent to
jump into any dock knowing how much it
takes and how much of your your life you
you have to really give up to to what I
believe is tell tell a good story okay
and I know you you open the film with
some pretty heavy self disclosure was
that something you intended to do right
off the bat there was some really heavy
stuff that I resonated with but
sometimes documentarians don't always
talk about some of their motives behind
making a film right I mean I I don't
know that the idea behind that the dock
was always gonna be something that we we
put into the the documentary during the
process we had a lot of feedback
sessions like at least 30 probably less
than 50 somewhere in that range and one
of the people that we were really lucky
to have sit with us and give us some
feedback was Boaz yakin do you know who
that is he's an amazing director and the
movie was pretty much cut but he was
like I'm not sure I understand the
premise and we're like really how could
you be how could you miss the premise
and so because our introduction hadn't
set it up well enough so
it was something that I I wanted to be a
part of the movie but I hadn't figured
out exactly how yet so I kind of pitched
it to the producers that we go back and
tell a bit of my story so that people
have a better understanding of why it is
that we're exploring these character
journeys and so the reason behind my
interest was then incorporated into the
beginning of the film so in in all of
the sort of the sessions of watching the
various cuts that was those were his
notes to you to really tell your story
so it sort of solidified it it was just
very simple and kind of like we all felt
like we were five because he said I
don't know I don't I just I just don't
get the the premise and we're like uh
like how do you miss the premise I mean
that's like pretty you know we all felt
pretty we put so much work into into the
movie and something that seems so
obvious to us and that exceedingly
obvious to me because it was my my
reason behind making the movie but
sometimes you're so close to things that
you can't you can't always tell which is
what I think it's so important to I
guess like even if you're you're a
screenwriter you know to open yourself
up you know to two people and be able to
accept critique you know so that you can
make your your project better was it
your intention to make a food
documentary I mean there's been so many
these days and it's so much more than
just a food documentary but was that
your initial intention we did not want
to make another food doc and I respect
and love a lot of those those
documentaries and I think would be
difficult to compete with with them at
this point and probably unnecessary and
I also didn't really want to go about
trying to expose any more bad food
systems in any more detail or you know
get into kind of like attacking our
corporate system or anything like that
and
I feel like it's almost kind of like a
an affirmative idea that if you tell a
story and focus on what the negative
aspects are that people are gonna walk
walk away with this sort of brain
recording going it's not okay it's not
okay it's not okay rather than tell all
the reasons why everything is okay and
how easy it is to resolve some of our
age-old issues which for for gardening
which one of the thing that I did
discover because I'm not a gardener was
that it's some things like like
breathing it's so innate but so many
intelligent people and capable people
are afraid of planting tomatoes or
afraid of lettuce and including myself
and so I really wanted to make the story
something that was made gardening more
attainable for busy people for for
everyone and come at it from a really
positive place and I think I'm getting
that sort of feedback I feel like people
are going to dialogues and are very
inspired after after seeing the movie at
the the screenings that we've done so
far very much so and I don't want to
give away too much about the film but I
love the way you incorporate the stories
the gardening the photos the music I'm
sorry I don't suppose the drawings you
have the illustrations so I think that
it's nice that there's a spiritual
component to the gardening it seems like
people really gain a healing through
doing this and so I think that was the
biggest takeaway for me so yeah it's so
much more than a food doc and I really
love the film when you set out to make
it was it and forgive me a you know my
own self disclosure I didn't know much
about my own father so I hope that's
okay to ask you more about this but were
you also seeking answers about your own
father and in turn really who you are
because a lot of that's missing when you
don't know
other parent it's true I I was curious
about South Los Angeles because my my
mom brought me up in in Hollywood so I'm
interracial child and I had the sort of
eclectic white mom and my very charming
black dad from South LA and they weren't
really together so much my parents but
he would take me to South LA quite often
and it's not like my life was you know
so cushiony and in Hollywood but I did
see a huge disparity between the two
areas when I was a kid and I think it's
something that I just went about my life
and just never quite addressed and so I
stopped seeing my dad after I was 9 and
I just was very curious to know if you
know we're in America we we have this
idea of like pulling yourself up by your
own bootstraps that you know if you have
the impetus to do something you should
just be able to do it and my question is
is about resources and maybe that's true
maybe you don't need a lot of support
and maybe you don't need a lot of
resources but there is there some things
that my dad that I saw him do and the
challenges that he faced and in his life
that I wanted to see if that's the same
in the area is that my own experience
and if if he did have tougher
circumstances what was up what was he up
against and then that kind of does
connect for me to to gardening and you
know ron finley saying that he can
change lives through through planting a
seed in an area that is notoriously
dangerous so it was a definite personal
exploration so you know because you've
been a dancer for years and you you've
also did I believe a
narrative film before this wasn't your
first one but first doc was there a
moment or did you I know Ron fiddly did
this amazing TED talk that has like over
2.5 million views what came first the
meeting Ron or wanting to search for it
was well my my father I had found out I
had like some people from my family
reach out with these strange numbers on
my phone I'm going who are these people
from like you know calling me and it
would turn at my father was was sick and
wanted to see me and so that was kind of
a strange like why does he want to see
me like I don't really know him that
well you know you're an adult and you
get through your life without a father
figure and you don't feel like you ness
it's not a sad thing I just don't you
know I don't know him or need him I
guess so I that kind of pulled me back
into the the area and then it was
somewhat organic because I had already
been talking to the producers at delario
films about maybe something that was
more in the narrative platform and they
brought up they showed me Ron Finley LA
Times article and that inspired the
conversation so it was kind of one of
those things that just sort of happens
like serendipitously you know when
you're looking for something and
everything kind of falls into place that
creates a project interesting so that
yeah and I believe the article was about
how one of his neighbors turn him in for
planting vegetables and there were some
city ordinance that he can't grow
vegetables like on his medium in front
of his house yeah it's some ridiculous
thing yeah yeah you can't get the part
you can't plant carrots in your Parkway
this is illegal but there there are now
laws that have changed due to Ron Finley
and Ron Finley's efforts now it's it is
possible to plant vegetables in the
Parkway where all the grass is
now it is legal in Los Angeles County
however across the United States it is
still primarily illegal to plant where
the the grass is just a very antiquated
law and I think it was interesting when
when I was following following Ron
Finley I went to the City Council
meeting and you know I tend to think oh
it's just bureaucracy and I think of
them them as they and you know I we
can't get anything done and I feel like
people are you know feel apathetic about
politics and then here I see the City
Council and these people are very much a
lot like me they just are doing that job
and they've got to deal with paperwork
to make things go and the majority of
them don't want to stop people from
eating healthy they they have kids of
their own they they see that that it's
too expensive to eat at Whole Foods
every day no matter what neighborhood
you're from and they want the laws to
change what they were worried about were
things like getting the city getting
sued because if somebody plans a spiky
plant or something that a kid eats
that's somewhat you know toxic or which
those arguments are they make sense and
they don't because you know I'm sure
that there's trees that you can't eat
either you know but it was just like
getting through this like kind of big
bureaucracy to get us to this this place
we're where we are now
I know Ron is is a force of nature in
the film no pun intended sorry and and
he's one of the producers on the on the
movie but you you also had so many other
interesting individuals each one no one
really paled in comparison that each
one's story was really unique was there
any one or a few people that you had to
cut out of the film and if so what was
your reasoning for having to not use
their interviews there are two people
that it breaks my heart that are not in
a movie well one is because that you
only have so many minutes to tell
everybody's story and if you divide up
you know 80 minutes
that's 20 minutes each person not
including Ron Finley
to have a beginning middle and an end
it's just it's not possible to do I
believe more than more than that and
tell a true personal story but we had a
one woman named Miss Teresa who lived in
Inglewood and her apartment overlooked a
basketball court in an area that was
pretty crime ridden this is an older
woman from the south who was quite
lonely and had southern southern manners
and felt a little bit alienated there
and then this organization called social
justice Learning Institute had put in a
really simple about 12 garden boxes on
top of the concrete like got rid of the
the basketball court and slowly but
surely kids are coming out and planting
things and asking questions and here she
is now instead of overlooking this
basketball court she's looking at these
garden boxes and seeing kids out there
and then she goes out there with all of
her knowledge from the south and starts
teaching these little ones and then the
seniors from across the street
are coming out because a lot of them
can't feed themselves so they're
actually eating from the garden so that
now Miss Teresa is meeting some of her
neighbors that are her peers and the
area has gang members but nobody is you
know doing anything bad to the garden
they are protecting the garden now
because they respect it and love it and
it creates this community now where
everybody's coming out and either eating
from it or meeting their neighbors and
she it's completely changed her life
these twelve boxes these garden boxes
very simple garden boxes so that's miss
Teresa I'm hoping that we can include
some of her
the VOD and then also there is Hanif who
had a garden on the the Compton Creek it
was an illegal garden that one for sure
is illegal he he lives in a senior home
in in Compton and would he was a Vietnam
vet he was a paratrooper with PTSD and
he used the garden for therapy it really
wasn't to to eat from it and he's he's
hilarious because he doesn't like the
other seniors they're like old people
they talk too much they're you know they
get in his way and they they're always
trying to you know what do you got over
there what are you growing and he's you
know reluctant but he he opens up as
well he's amazing he's like into Native
American spirituality so he stages off
his plants and he's always trying new
new ways of planting because it's hard
to get water over there so he's he's
also one of my favorites but we had to
cut him out because he's so close to
Hosea so if we're also pushing to put
his story in the the extras for VOD as
well well speaking of reluctance I
noticed with several of the the subjects
for lack of a better word that at first
their body language they were turned
away from the camera and then once the
movie got going I definitely saw them
trust you at least it appeared that way
to us to the viewer yeah how did you how
did you break that down or was it not a
really breaking down I was just letting
it be I think it was a mixture of time
which I guess is letting it be and also
being open and vulnerable myself because
if I'm not open they have no reason to
tell me anything personal or forget that
I'm there so I had to forge real
friendships with people that I would not
have gotten to know otherwise so it
really forced me to grow as a human
being and
sometimes you think oh director I can be
introverted I can you know I can just
get behind the camera and like whisper
my my ideas to people and you know hire
an actor who was gonna you know take
those ideas it's their job to make it
happen you know but with the doc you
know you get hung up on a lot I showed
up at Gardens for like a four o'clock
appointment and would wait in my car
till like eight or nine and nobody would
show up you want to get angry you you
can't those people's lives they don't
necessarily want you know want a camera
in their face you know contrary to
popular belief not everybody wants that
the camera in their face so yeah I think
it was just perseverance not not getting
upset if if people don't pick up the
phone if they don't return your call
that made me grow also usually like once
someone doesn't call you back once
you're like fine whatever you know I
would call eight nine twelve sixteen
times get stood up and just keep showing
up with my camera wow that's interesting
so so maybe you know being less
sensitive was some of the the outcome
you had less sensitive not taking things
personal and also I I learned that you
know it's so it's so cliche but not
taking no for an answer I mean just and
it really does seem that it most knows
can turn into a yes you know if you're
just if I think that if you are coming
from a good place and you you are
trustworthy and and I think that there
was definitely a bond that I had to
create with people so that they realized
that any portion of their life that was
gonna be exposed would be something that
they would feel okay with so they
trusted me to represent them in the best
light that I
can and still tell this story do you
think um that people were afraid of
being judged being misunderstood was
that part of it or just even just having
to acknowledge their own stuff and it
was scary to have to then maybe they'd
have to watch it and I mean there was a
lot of painful stuff they talked about
that why they wouldn't yeah I think
that's a that's a really that's a hard
question to answer in some ways because
I don't know that people they know that
you're doing a documentary but you know
they're like because you don't I'm gonna
be on YouTube like but they don't know
when you say documentary if that's three
minutes you know or what what that means
exactly so I don't know that people are
thinking that introspectively as far as
what what they're gonna appear as but I
would definitely say that I find it
somewhat challenging to sit with my
characters in some moments during the
movie because it is their life you know
kind of flashing right back back at them
and I can't imagine what that even even
feels like does this interview can is
like can be unnerving but to do you have
to dissect yourself and that's got to be
rough I don't know I don't even know
really how how what it feels like to be
a documentary subject and and and how
that felt but they I think they're all
okay with it so was there a point where
you said okay you can see your
interviews now or did you show them
dailies how did that work I absolutely
did not show anybody dailies I think I
showed maybe like a few still pictures
just to say hey look how cool you look
in this I haven't seen you in two weeks
you're not answering the phone
look how cool you look and then that
sometimes would help and sometimes it
didn't but yeah definitely not because
they didn't want people to feel aware of
themselves you know so that they would
know how how they look and
how they're coming across and I didn't
share anything about how I felt their
story arc was or and I tried not to lead
anybody down any path that would make
them self-aware when I was asking
questions either I feel like it would be
like if I went to your house and you
made me lasagna from your garden and we
just chatted and I asked you questions
all over the gamut and then cut it
together to tell a story about how great
you are at making lasagna and you know
how much care you put into it and I
would hope that I would captured those
those elements from the question that I
asked but I wouldn't tell you that I was
after that okay so so when you're good
because I mean you you get some each
person each character has some pretty
interesting and and at times very
troubling turns how long were you
following at least a year Wow yeah and
it's a lot of time a lot of time spent
in South LA a lot of time in my car a
lot of time not being able to find
anything to eat because it is South LA
which is a food desert which was like
you know kind of this existential like
wait I'm making a dhaka bout not being
able to eat in South LA and I can't find
anything to eat you know it's like but
yeah a lot live basically you know
living there for a year not sleeping
there but living with people very very
closely interesting and so when when you
are turning on the camera and asking
questions again you you were saying it
wasn't so much leading them down a
certain path it was just how was your
day what happened but very innocent
right I mean I would I would have an
idea of what I was asking about and I
mean they're not stupid they you know if
I'm asked spicy about jail for instance
he knows that we're interested in that
portion of his of his story so yeah and
that was apparent at taunt you know you
could definitely see him maybe putting
up a wall and then letting you in and
and but toward the end it definitely
seemed like people really did trust you
and that was
interesting to see that in the beginning
that the sort of turning away from the
camera even the physical and then
opening up more so I thought that was
fascinating just curious what you shot
on a c300 oh come and then also use the
5d I found the fuzzy kind of hard
especially at 12 noon like I can't look
at that LCD and get it focused well
enough and I know that there's some like
attachments that you can put on there
which I found out in retrospect to
create almost like a viewfinder for the
LCD and I didn't really figure out the
filters as well with that camera I
really loved the c300 it was heavy as
all get-out and I know they're marketing
it has like this lighter camera like
that my girl arms after a while just
would start sinking and then I would use
my elbow and place it into my hip like
as if my hip is the tripod to take the
weight and sort of curve around the
camera all day long and then especially
Kimani because we I mean I don't want
the story about Kimani to be like this
adult viewpoint you know I want it to be
from her perspective so I was constantly
in this sort of plie of sorts you know
shooting Kimani hunched over and yes did
you have another TP or it was all yes
okay I did um I was like going through
all the the cameras I got I got on off
on a tangent but we used also the
bollocks which I didn't shoot on the
bollocks
we had edit growl the amazing edit growl
who shot a single man and he shot
suffragette the Meryl Streep movie that
just got released and so he was our DP
for for Ron primarily
and JB I can't pronounce his last name
yeah I saw the light yeah I have it here
somewhere too sorry JB but he he he did
a lot of our we shot on the the Lumix a
lot of our traveling shots we had we got
a car amount and did that he did a lot
of that he did some b-roll of of Ron's
garden got like some beautiful amazing
stuff there another DP John
yikes I can't remember his last name
either but he came in for for one day so
but 85 90 % is when there was like one
on one interview stuff or in the garden
with the characters it's it's me the
GoPro the our drone shots was our
producer Christopher Leggett he got
those he's just like a tech head so I'm
afraid of the drones I mean we weren't
sure if it was yeah if you got a
helicopter or what so that looks great
the over shots of the card and when
you're when you were in South LA and
there were some you know police shots
and different things
what was your protocol for shooting some
of that I mean how fearful were you not
of just a neighborhood but the police as
well not wanting you to shoot them right
well the thing is is like there are
police driving around South Los Angeles
like there are like you know buses going
by in Hollywood it's just a constant
president's insane with the helicopters
and I never really felt like anything
was gonna happen to me if I aimed camera
as long as I'm not antagonizing anyone
so yeah and as far as being afraid in
that area
think that's kind of like a two-fold
question because I know that the the
crime rate is higher there so that's in
my my mind while I'm there but it also
if I'm walking around any part of the
city with 14,000 dollars worth of
equipment a girl all by myself with one
eye covered and earphones on and can't
see behind me you know I'm always gonna
feel a little edgy you know so I
definitely was I would say more on edge
than I would be but it's hard to
determine because I feel like I'm a
little ballsy in that sense like
especially if I'm trying to tell a story
that's not about me and for I believe a
greater cause then I'll put myself in
situations that are you know worth worth
not my life but you know my life but and
lastly just just wrapping up here were
you surprised though by how many people
were intrigued by a female with all this
gear on walking down the street I know
you said before people were hesitant but
were there some that were just like wow
what are you doing like what are you
making I did get that I definitely got
people stopping me on the street to ask
about about the the equipment and what
I'm doing and I got a lot of support to
sister out in the hood with my you know
with my gear and like hey tell my story
tell my story you know it's like you got
any listen to my story I got a lot of
that you're like okay let me take notes
I'm I'm I'm busy right now I can't do
your story give me your information but
I did get a lot of support out there I
think people I thought it was actually
really great to be sort of an example in
South LA of like not only just like a
black woman or mixed woman making a
movie as an example in the area where
there's no film school that I know of in
South LA and then also being female and
hopefully empowering other women that
even if they're not going to be a
filmmaker just seeing someone do
something that looks like out of the box
or something that we
don't see regular regularly that I I
think that it definitely was inspiring
for for people to see absolutely thank
you thank you